at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking personal mobility this episode
is brought to you by 4 Sigma tech
founded by the genius Finn's who lit the
internet on fire and you may have heard
of their mushroom coffee which features
chaga and lion's mane which has taken
Silicon Valley by storm I use it pretty
much every day either that or the chugga
which is decaf there's a separate
version and I use both of these
primarily for focus and productivity
they just get you going light you up
like a Christmas tree so definitely
check it out people are always asking me
what I use for cognitive enhancement and
for right now this is the answer I try
to force this on all of my houseguests
it is a hell of a thing if I have
employees or people come over who are
working on projects with me I always try
to feed it to them because I'm going to
get the limitless effect gets a lot more
out of them the first time I mentioned
this product and for sig Matic on the
podcast their products sold out in less
than a week so you may want to check
them out soon if you're listening to
this and the coffee tastes like coffee
it takes just seconds to prepare with
hot water and oddly enough only includes
40 milligrams of caffeine so it has less
than half of what you would get in a
regular cup of coffee I don't get any
jitters acid reflux or any stomach burn
any of that it's very unusual and very
very cool so if you don't like caffeine
they also offer very strong but caffeine
free mushroom elixirs which I will
sometimes have in the evening I find
chaga specifically to be very very
grounding and earthy so that is another
option and I have a cupboard full of
their products at the moment which is
right around the corner in my kitchen
you can try something you can try a
sample pack which is great also right
now by going to four sig Matic calm
forward slash Tim that's force
maduk fo you are SI GMA TI c-calm
forward slash tim and use the code tim
TI m to get 20% off of your first order
and they're not that expensive anyway if
you are in the experimental mindset I do
not think you'll be disappointed
it's a try them well hello boys and
girls this is Tim Ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the Tim Ferriss show
where it is my job to tease out the
habits routines belief systems life
lessons from people who are the best at
what they do and the to hopefully give
you an opportunity to test those things
in your own life in this episode we have
a power couple
in fact but let's go back in time to
around 2009 or 2010 when I was given a
t-shirt and the t-shirt was an avatar as
in the film an avatar staff t-shirt and
on the front was a quote and the quote
was hope is not a strategy luck is not a
factor fear is not an option it is
attributed to James Cameron who is part
of the dynamic duo who will be featured
in this episode who's James Cameron you
asked James Cameron is a filmmaker and
deep-sea Explorer he is writer director
and producer of many films including the
Terminator aliens the abyss Terminator 2
True Lies Titanic and Avatar both
Titanic and Avatar the highest-grossing
film of all time won the Golden Globe
for Best Director and Best Picture and
were nominated for a record number of
awards Cameron was also at the vanguard
of the 3d Renaissance developing
cutting-edge 3d camera systems as an
explorer in 2012
Cameron set the world's solo deep diving
record of 35,000 787 feet in the
Challenger Deep in a vehicle of his own
design he is a dedicated
environmentalist and he has founded the
Avatar Alliance foundation to take
action on climate change energy policy
to forestation indigenous rights ocean
conservation and sustainable agriculture
he's currently in production on Avatar 2
3 4 & 5 you can find him on twitter at
jim cameron susie amos cameron his wife
is a noted environmental ad
mother of five and the author of OMD
which is one meal a day OMD subtitle the
simple plant-based program to save your
health save your waistline and save the
planet and the founder of the OMD
movement a multi-pronged effort to
transform eating habits and the food
system she was also a founder of plant a
power task force focused on showing the
impact of animal agricultural on climate
change in the environment founded in
2012 with her husband that is Jim and
Craig McCaw in 2005 she found at Mews
School the first school in the country
to be 100% solar-powered with zero waste
and a 100% organic plant-based lunch
program additionally she is founder of
verdiant Foods Cameron family farms and
food forest organics along with red
carpet green dress as an actor she's
been featured in more than 25 films
including the usual suspects in Titanic
you can find her online Facebook Susie a
camera that's Susie Suz why Twitter
Susie musing and Instagram Susie Amos
Cameron a few housekeeping notes right
up front there are two other episodes
that I'm publishing simultaneously with
James and Susie on the tribe of mentors
podcast I want to do an experiment and
split things up a little bit for a whole
host of reasons in the shorter episode
that you'll find on the tribe of mentors
podcast I include their answers to some
of my common questions including what is
bad advice you often hear in your areas
of expertise or in your industry and
I'll give you a teaser for that do what
you love is is one of the answers that
is elaborated on favorite books books
that have been most gifted to others and
then favorite failures so failures they
have learned the most from and the
second episode which is going to be on
the tribe mentors podcast is the full
audio also not to be missed
there is a bonus in text so James
mentions in the full audio that unlike
on previous films he did not get sick
during the simultaneous filming /
production of Avatar 2 & 3 which is
astonishing considering as he put it
that quote
meaning all staff no coming in when they
sign up that it's going to be the most
difficult production in human history
and quote so how did he do it he credits
his stamina and health during that
period to his new routine including
plant-based diet supplements exercise
and so on so I asked him for a concrete
daily calendar with exact food
supplements times and so on which he
provided so you can find James super
dialed in daily routine for after 2:00
and 3:00 at Tim blog /ik James Cameron
that's Tim de Blanc for / James Cameron
alright so some of you who are long-term
listeners have no doubt heard multiple
guests on to discuss the ketogenic diet
to discuss alternate approaches to food
and health and I thought that this
episode would be a good opportunity to
give some airtime to discussion of
plant-based diets and it should also be
underscored that there are chapters in
the 4-hour body two of them with the
legendary ultra endurance athlete scott
jurek about plant-based diets and even
if you disagree with perhaps plant-based
diets or any of the arguments you might
hear from susie and james that suggests
listening for at least three reasons
number one there's plenty of non plant
talk and we jump right into it with
discussion of of how they both respond
to feeling overwhelmed or distracted the
second is patience in this podcast I do
my best to in a gentle way sometimes not
so gentle but often a gentle way expose
people to different viewpoints different
perspectives in the world which is why I
have on very often for instance someone
who's highly religious like Rabbi
Jonathan Sacks
and then I will have just a few episodes
later someone like Sam Harris who is PhD
in neuroscience and very well known for
being an atheist I might have someone
who is far left and then someone who is
far right because I like to focus on
some of the commonalities and also the
thought processes the only way you can
understand your argument your position
best is to also understand the opposing
viewpoints or it says number two this is
exercise in patience especially in these
divisive times I think it is a
worthwhile exercise and third OMD one
meal per day that is plant-based I would
recommend even if you don't plan on
converting to fully plant-based as a
consciousness practice and an exercise
which is something I very often do I
will I will impose certain constraints
on my eating eliminate a certain food
product or I will insist that I eat
based on a spectrum of color as a way to
make my subconscious or automatic
behaviors ie eating more conscious so
that I'm more aware of what I am doing
and the decisions I am making so those
are a few of the many reasons I would
suggest listening to this and without
further ado let's just jump right into
it with Suzy and James Cameron well hold
off baby well Tim first of all we want
to say hi and when we first met you we
were all flying around in the parabolic
flight with well Elon Musk and bunch
other crazy folks yeah doing somersaults
in zero-g super fun super fun so hey Tim
thanks for having us on the show we're
honored to be here yeah really really
excited just I guess you still call a
podcast a show I guess yeah yeah Tim
Ferriss show ok well then I guess it's
called the Tim Ferriss show then it's
got to be a show
when you feel overwhelmed or unfocused
or have lost your focus temporarily what
do you do if helpful what questions do
you ask yourself so what do I do when I
feel overwhelmed I clean off my desk
just would have you know working at a
high pace you know everything piles up
and just the act of cleaning off my desk
like a reset it's like it's like power
cycle a computer it's a reboot and I
usually find that about half the stuff
that's accumulated I can throw out
mm-hmm and the other half I have to I
have to put in piles you know I have to
put them in the right place so now I'm
prioritizing now I'm thinking oh well
that's that's still important so I think
that you know that if you're if you're a
team leader you've got to get your own
priorities straight before you can
generate priorities for that for the
team and I've found that whenever I hit
one of those moments I also find it's
great to take a day off or even half a
day off just force yourself to take a
day off not not to go play but to just
reorganize right and just you know kind
of write down the series of priorities
are kind of memos to yourself and out of
that I typically will generate things
that I hand out to my team to give them
their marching orders to kind of get us
back on track and it's amazing how
things just pop into focus and solutions
present themselves because I haven't
stopped running I haven't gotten off the
treadmill until that moment to you know
to lift my head out of the day-to-day
battle to think about how are we going
to really win this war it was a
something like a big film production is
is like a campaign that takes place over
sometimes a period of years and if you
don't if you don't take a moment out to
kind of look at the big picture so most
of the major strategic decisions that
I've made during the during the
productions of the to habit are film so
far over the last couple years have come
from that that down day right that catch
up day it's not about taking a day off
taking a nap that's a good idea - mm-hmm
and you know go swim or play with the
kids or whatever you got to do that too
but just take a day for
yourself with no distractions to just
get everything in in order that helps me
a lot if nothing else I just feel better
about it right I come in there's a clean
desk here's some memos you guys go do
the work well I think we're really
similar on that I mean I have a tendency
to walk through the house and get
ridiculously overwhelmed with you know
all the kids and the cats and the dogs
and the bearded dragon people yeah so I
always like to go in and just reorganize
the house but I always start with my
office as well and I I like to take a
big piece of typing paper and write out
you know I create columns and I write
out all my emails that I need to do and
all my calls that I need to do and then
there's a whole section in there just
for household things work things and all
of those and you know I know that the
children are learning this as well
because when they you know of course
they roll their eyes when I walk in and
say okay we're gonna we're gonna take a
clean day an organizing day and here are
some boxes for giveaways they roll their
eyes but in the end they love it and
they feel better and then they get into
it and they get into it so it's it's um
it's the same sort of thing and and
taking a walk and then realizing like
okay what is the first thing I can do
that's going to get me on that journey
towards my towards my goal but always
keeping that goal in mind of whatever
that is you know sometimes the best way
to solve the problem is to walk away
from it for a second yeah it's
counterintuitive for first type type-a
types it just bash our heads against the
problem all day long boom boom boom boom
day after day you know I had an epiphany
while I was writing avatar I was working
down in New Zealand him office was kind
of in the in the country and and you
know is just heaven it was just
impossible to solve some of the dramatic
problems I just couldn't I couldn't
solve it I couldn't fix the script and I
was sitting I just walked away i sat
down sat outside and there was a glass
cover to the veranda and I watched this
big fly and he was trying to get out and
he was banging against the glass
and he just kept hitting the glass over
and over and over and over because
that's how his little chip was
programmed you go toward the light you
go toward the sky and he couldn't get to
the sky all he had to do was drop down
fly three feet sideways and come out but
he couldn't process and I thought how
often am i that fly how often is there
some higher level of perspective that I
lack in my chip that I'm missing that is
so simple that some fourth dimensional
being could look at the problem we go oh
you idiot you just drop down go over
three feet and you're out but the fly
couldn't do it and I thought what am I
not seeing you know and that's when I
went back to first principles and I
looked I looked at the whole thing from
from a higher level I got out of the
trenches for that moment and that's how
I that's how I solved the problem yeah I
think also too is learning when to
recognize when you're hitting that
window and also learning to recognize
when it's the path of least resistance
because you know you're on the right
path when doors just continue - oh well
that's true that's the opposite when you
win that's the other thing that's
important to recognize when things are
breaking your way when when you have
momentum when you're not hitting the
glass mm-hmm
you take advantage of it right and you
ride that tailwind but there's a
difference - it's it's when you know you
want to do something and you feel really
strongly about it and you have a lot of
people around you saying no and you
shouldn't do it and it's gonna be too
hard and that I mean I know it works for
you that way but I mean that just lights
and Ferno under my butt it's like okay
really no watch me
yeah I'd love to say that to my team on
Avatar oh well we shouldn't do that guys
cuz that's going to be hard exactly when
they when they no coming in when they
sign out that it's going to be the most
difficult production in human history
just by its nature where every blade of
grass in in the entire world that we're
creating is done as is created by
somebody by a computer artist or by
some kind of algorithm that self-growing
or whatever you know by definition it's
gonna be it's gonna be hard right you're
there because it's hard you're doing it
because it's hard you know that's
because that's how you measure yourself
against that challenge and that's why
everybody's that's on the Avatar team is
there because they know it's going to be
the hardest [ __ ] they ever work
on yeah and they want that know they'll
all go whine about it later and say that
was the hardest [ __ ] I ever
worked on and that's why I have this
reputation as a cruel taskmaster but in
fact they've all showed up because they
want to do that they want to climb that
mountain and they've learned from it I
mean that's how they're like the
teachers at Muse they're teaching in a
way they've never nobody teaches that
way and it's really challenging they
learn now the kids don't like holidays
because they don't get to go to school
if you could have one gigantic billboard
anywhere with anything on it
metaphorically speaking getting a
message out to millions or billions what
would it say and why could be a few
words or a paragraph if helpful it can
be someone else's quote are there any
quotes you can think of or live your
life by yeah I'm terrible with quotes
and you know that sort of thing but I
think I would I would sum up
philosophically what I would ask people
to do which is to live in a more
connected way to see yourself as part of
a big global system and know that every
action you take has a consequence
every choice you make as a consumer
whether it's you know using plastics or
using electricity or replacing that that
iPhone that's only six months old
because there's a better one that that
has an impact on somebody somewhere or
some animal somewhere or some ecosystem
somewhere that you know when I when I
look at the history of the human race up
until now and this all doesn't go on the
Billboard by the way I want to try to
cut that's this down but I look at the
history up until now we've been all
about expansion it's an endless hunger
to
to conquer and expand and and and we've
we've filled the planet we're like a
more like a bacterial culture that
rapidly expands to the edge of the petri
dish while we're hitting the edge of the
petri dish now and so everything that
always worked throughout human history
is not going to work going forward we're
gonna have to have some fundamental
change in the way we think we're gonna
have to stop being takers and start
being caretakers or we won't survive
it's that simple now maybe maybe it's 50
years maybe it's a hundred years maybe
it's 200 years but it's not going to go
on the way it's been going on and we're
going to have to change and I think it's
a change for the better it's a change
that's more empathic it's more
compassionate it you know so I guess I
would say stop being a taker or take
take less and care take more and I mean
that very generally as well think about
how decisions that you make and things
you do are affecting people in other in
other countries and all those people
that are coming up in that big caravan a
lot of them have been displaced by by
droughts their farms of collapse and
they can't grow there they can't grow
their food it's not just about drug
violence and all that sort of thing
especially in in Guatemala there are
there are you know hundreds of thousands
if not millions of people on the move
from farms that have collapsed due to
unprecedented drought that's that's
drier conditions than they've ever had
in recorded history and and the ability
of science to look back hundreds of
thousands of years
Lotte's climate change at work and if
that particular series of droughts has
not caused specifically by climate
change it's a pretty damn good
bellwether
for what it's going to look like when
hundreds of thousands and then and then
ultimately hundreds of millions of
people are on the move because of
climate change so the choices that we're
making in our energy consumption and our
consumption and natural resources in our
consumption of foods is impacting other
people in other parts of the world it'll
eventually come back to haunt us with
the kinds of political systems that are
now you know taking over all over the
world these protectionist isolationist
nationalistic hyper nationalistic
populist
systems that are that are about closing
borders and shutting down and all that
sort of thing I see it all interlinked
and I see it all as a feedback loop
that's just going to get worse and horse
so I would say we have to change this
from the inside out from the way we view
the world and our place in it and so
yeah
stop being a taker start being a
caretaker right that's my billboard when
you're talking about the timeline the
United Nations just came out a couple of
weeks ago with a report and from the
IPCC saying that we have to do something
by 2032 to turn things around if we are
going to survive on this earth and you
know one of the things that that I
really resonate with is the the Native
American tribes the First Nations they
always say no matter what you're doing
realize that it's going to affect the
next seven generations so just being
really conscious in your everyday
actions and tread lightly tread lightly
on the earth yeah yeah I mean I look we
all struggle to do it and where we don't
want to come off as holier-than-thou
that's the thing about about vegans in
general as they all they're all such you
know [ __ ] tell you Joe
okay how many vegans does it take to
screw in a lightbulb
doesn't matter we're better than you all
right right so you know so the the
problem is people tend to reject reject
what you know what we could tell them
but I you know I think the answer does
say well don't don't take our word for
it read the books it's all online the
problem is that people tend to entrench
around their belief systems and now with
with the with digital news the way it is
we can pre-select the inputs we can
pre-select our inputs to support only
what we already believe and so everybody
lives in these in these kind of isolated
echo Cham
you know and it's all exacerbated by by
social media and so on and so it's
really going to be another thing that
we're going to have to just get a whole
lot better at as a as a species and as a
society is checking our facts and
looking at alternative opinions and
especially look at the at the facts that
the the that the other guys have if they
have any come from confirmation bias
swerve alright so next question what are
you currently most excited about alright
I'm not going to talk about about
plant-based nutrition okay other than to
say for one second that I was pretty
hopeless about being able to get a
handle on climate change just looking at
it from an energy perspective and
transportation and all that and and when
I realized the environmental connection
from eating plant-based I got excited
about that but that's kind of old news
cuz that's six years ago for us I guess
right now I'm excited about the Avatar
films I get I have the coolest job in
the world I get to go in and and create
a world an ecosystem populated with
creatures and cool characters and do
that all day long and you know live in
that fantasy world so yeah I'm pretty
excited about it
yeah so just to piggyback on you know
feeling hopeful because I am going to
talk about plant-based eating Jim
actually has a t-shirt and one of the
lines on it says hope is not a strategy
and he's a doomsday kind of guy if you
watch his movies they're kind of like
into the world apocalyptic and he never
used the word hope and six and a half
years ago we were walking on the beach
and he said to me for the first time in
my life I feel hopeful and needless to
say I almost you know fell into the surf
but it's planted a seed you know that
that the more people we can
to eat plant-based the more we can move
the needle on climate change and it was
that seed that was planted that made me
think about creating content and writing
a book and I'm most excited about about
the book that I wrote about my book you
get to be changing one meal a day for
the planet and it starts out with the
education of the health I worked with a
brain trust of doctors so it's very very
heavily researched in the medical field
around plant-based eating and then I
worked with people from Chatham House
and Oxford University in Loma Linda
climate scientists to help me with the
the environmental impacts of animal
agriculture and then it's a guide it's a
guide of how to do one meal a day or two
meals a day or blow up your kitchen like
Jim and I did and go cold turkey that's
recipe shopping list meal plans and I'll
hold your hand I won't judge you it's
it's not about being perfect
you can keep your burger if you want to
it's just about one meal a day OMD all
right so I think there's one more
question there is one more question and
if you had a request and asked or
suggestion for the listeners of this
podcast what would it be oh I think
people that listen to Tim and his guests
are looking for hacks to make their life
better to to learn how to live in this
this perplexing world and and and live
better and kind of be smarter so I think
that you know I would just say read a
lot check your facts and you know don't
don't don't follow us because we're so
sweet and compelling check the facts
yeah just the facts ma'am yeah I mean
you know it's all out there but I would
say also take to take the be willing to
look outside your confirmation bias
bubble and I I like I forced and
challenged myself to do this all the
time to get outside
to get outside that bubble and so you
know whatever your beliefs are ask
yourself one where they came from
when did you double down on that and
what have you done to look at it sort of
from an objective point of view and you
know I try to do that as much as
possible when something comes along that
I don't understand that doesn't fit my
belief system like you know let me just
give an example like Allan savory's
approach to regenerative agriculture
with you know grass-fed beef and all the
claims that were made around that I
looked into it and I thought well maybe
there's something here and I went pretty
far down the rabbit hole on that before
and and looked at the science on both
sides of it and ultimately saw that it
wasn't the right answer but uh but I
didn't just reject it out of hand
because it didn't fit my my you know my
belief system right well I think my ask
would be to take the OMD pledge I have a
and pledge one meal a day or two meals a
day or go all in it because it'll help
your health it'll help the planet it'll
help your the animals your waistline and
your sex life yes yeah not necessarily
in that order
anyway um thanks Tim thanks Tim this was
really fun and thanks for having us on
it's been a pleasure thank you yeah
thank you
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me and
would you enjoy getting a short email
for me every Friday if that provides a
little morsel of fun before the weekend
and five bullet Friday is a very short
email where I share the coolest things
I've found or that I've been pondering
over the week that could include
favorite new albums that I've discovered
it could include gizmos and gadgets and
all sorts of weird [ __ ] that I've
somehow dug up in the the world of the s
tarek as I do it could include favorite
articles that I have read and that I've
shared with my close friends for
instance and it's very short it's just a
little tiny bite of goodness before you
head off for the weekend so if you want
to receive that check it out
just go to 4-hour workweek dot-com
that's 4-hour workweek calm I'll spell
out and just drop in if your email and
you'll get the very next one and if you
sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by 4
Sigma Dec founded by the genius Finn's
who lit the internet on fire and you may
have heard of their mushroom coffee
features chaga and lion's mane which has
taken Silicon Valley by storm I use it
pretty much every day either that or the
chaga which is decaf a separate version
and I use both of these primarily for
focus and productivity they just get you
coin let you up like a Christmas tree so
definitely check it out people are
always asking me what I use for
cognitive enhancements and for right now
this is the answer I try to force this
on all of my houseguests it is a hell of
a thing if I have employees or people
come over who are working on projects
with me I always try to feed it to them
because I'm going to get the limitless
effect it's a lot more out of them the
first time I mentioned this product and
for sig Matic on the podcast your
products sold out in less than a week so
you may want to check them out soon if
you're listening to this and the coffee
tastes like coffee
it takes just seconds to prepare with
hot water and oddly enough only includes
40 milligrams of caffeine so it has less
than half of what you would get in a
regular cup of coffee I don't get any
jitters acid reflux or any stomach burn
any of that it's very unusual and very
very cool so if you don't like caffeine
they also offer very strong but caffeine
free mushroom villagers which I will
sometimes have in the evening I find
chaga specifically to be very very
grounding and Earth
so that is another option and I have a
cupboard full of their products at the
MoMA which is right around the corner in
my kitchen you can try something you can
try a sample pack which is great also
right now by going to for sig Matic
comport / Tim that's for sig Matic fo
you are SI g ma TI c compote / Tim and
use the code tim TI m to get 20% off of
your first order and they're not that
expensive anyway if you are in the
experimental mindset I do not think
you'll be disappointed to climb up
[Applause]
you
you